Picasso Hodari
les cigares d'un nipa académique tewara
Okajima Divina les années 60 et 70 étaient l'
endroit où les sentiments nationaux des
Groenlandais et leur fierté d'être
au Groenland devenaient dans et
sans cette force et cette
inspiration juvéniles pendant cette période, je ne
pense pas  que nous pourrions nous asseoir ici et parler
joyeusement de littérature granitique Je
pense à un chien ou à un château de daesil un sitar
nous n'avons aucune chance pour que nos
langues survivent si nous ne l'utilisons pas
nous-mêmes et cela devrait commencer dès la
naissance jusqu'à ce que vous  mourir, vous devez avoir un
élément solide d'infrastructure dans votre
pays où vos liquides et votre
culture sont placés et il doit être non
seulement parlé dans l'année de la
législature dans laquelle il doit être utilisé dans
tous les médias dans lesquels il doit être utilisé
les affaires donc dans l'éducation deviennent un jour
ou européanisées ou je suis un reconnu
n'ai aidé personne du tout dans
nos régions, vous devez nous respecter avec
le contexte étroit de la nation, nous n'avons pas
seulement des origines ethniques, nous sommes un nat  ion qui sont
placés dans nos pays que nous avons
été colonisés
et vous devez comprendre que la
colonisation détruira toujours les
peuples qui sont colonisés vous ne pouvez
rien changer sans combattre le
colonialisme le colonialisme est aussi à l'intérieur de
vous dans votre âme si vous ne le trouvez pas ainsi
donc il n'y a personne d'autre aux Nations Unies
ou qui que ce soit qui puisse empêcher votre
langue de mourir, c'est vous-même Oh mon Dieu,
tant de mal je les laisse à part ça
c'est une politique méchante et inhumaine de ne pas
respecter les langues qui sont parlées par les
gens eux-mêmes si vous  allez
éduquer les gens et vous n'utilisez pas
leurs langues, cela n'aide pas du tout
, c'est pourquoi le Groenland au cours des 30 dernières
années a très bien réussi à utiliser
notre propre langue dans l'éducation de la naissance
à la mort et il est important de
comprendre que  situation
deuxième si les Inuits ne travaillent pas
ensemble pour trouver une solution sur le
système d'écriture, alors l'un ou l'autre de nos
colliers survivra, il est donc
important que nous ayons  une orthographe commune
et que la coopération par
le biais des technologies martin est utilisée
afin que l'écriture dans l'antiquité occidentale puisse être
facilement comprise dans l'est du Groenland ou
qu'elle puisse être traduite immédiatement dans la
langue de l'énergie Inupiaq alaska aussi,
donc l'Intuit canadien a vraiment besoin de
discuter avec nous très  de près comment nous faisons
cela et pourquoi il devrait repartir de
zéro principalement pour tricher pour avoir
des professeurs de langue à l'école et
ne pas commencer demain mais aujourd'hui et
sinon notre comme ça va disparaître
j'ai dit qu'il n'était pas nécessaire de voir cela je n'en ai pas
besoin  pour prendre une douche, il ne s'agit pas de savoir quel
genre de sentiments vous avez pour une
langue ou l'autre mais pour votre propre
identité, il est important de respecter
et de comprendre d'abord votre propre identité, ce
qui est très important dans un
système éducatif colonialiste comme celui que nous avons dans la plupart des pays du
nord  Les institutions nord-américaines,
c'est comme si le
Groenland avait pu
changer cela, car nous
utilisons nos droits pour nous-mêmes.  détermination,
il est important de comprendre que
les décisions politiques ne peuvent être prises que si
vous avez le droit précisément à la
langue elle-même, il est également important de
comprendre que l'âme de l'Inde est
très forte et que nous ne sommes au total que
150 000 personnes,
comment cent cinquante  des milliers de personnes
ont survécu si longtemps, c'est des conditions climatiques si dures à
cause de notre âme
parce que nous avons cela ici qui sort de
notre bouche quand nous parlons dans notre
propre langue inuit et les
expressions artistiques qui en sortent sont
abondantes et les gens le reste  du
monde doit être pour en savoir un peu plus
sur la culture ennemie autre que les
descriptions très étroites d'esprit si vous
pouvez l'appeler des Inuits, ce n'est pas étrange une
situation étrange du tout que les gens peuvent
survivre dans les conditions les plus
dures  de tout ce qui n'est pas étrange
ce n'est pas étrange la
chose étrange est de savoir comment les blancs peuvent
survivre dans notre région parce que nous les aidons
sans notre aide vous ne pouvez pas  ne pas survivre dans
ces conditions difficiles, alors s'il vous plaît, ne
nous dites pas ce que nous pouvons, mais nous pouvons vous dire
ce que nous pouvons, comment nous avons fait cela et
donc dire au reste du monde que je
connais tellement de mal, j'ai dit qu'il ne fallait pas mourir maintenant
si nous devrions  faire quelque chose qui crée un
nouveau sentiment d'unité entre de toute façon,
alors je pense que
nous devrions travailler plus étroitement ensemble dans l'
éducation dans les politiques de Blackwood et
aussi pour permettre à notre côté artistique de
notre humanité d'avoir beaucoup plus de
place qu'aujourd'hui et de cette façon nous pouvons
survivre  beaucoup de crise à mon avis je
pense que cela ne prend qu'une décision personnelle
de faire ce dont nous avons besoin pour la création
d'un système d'écriture qui est commun et
nous pouvons tous le lire alors je suis sûr que
la prochaine édition de ce livre serait  être
beaucoup plus intéressant et nous
pourrons être fiers et dire eh bien cela est
né de la résilience de notre idée
que même les petites personnes comme nous les petites
nations comme nous peuvent sûrement jouer à des jeux
avec les grandes nations aussi et c'est
c'est le seul  raison w  ous sommes ici que
nous ne voulons pas payer avec notre culture
afin de suivre les souhaits de la majorité des gens
de quel genre de personnes nous devrions
être c'est cela devrait être notre propre décision
quel genre de personnes nous sommes parce que personne
ne peut enlever  notre identité même vous
pouvez colorer vos cheveux et mettre de fausses
choses sur votre visage mais cela ne
change pas ce qui est ici est le dans son
propre et c'est à la force motrice
sans leur ce n'est rien
qu'il dit assurez-vous de ne pas dire notre témoignage à
parler des problèmes du Colorado Clipper devrait connaître
la Lena